Welcome to the Broadmeadow refurbishment
presentation. The following images allow
us the chance to offer you a visual
representation of the proposed
refurbishment and decarbonization works
at Broadmeadow Sports Centre. Image one.
This image outlines the existing ground floor
plan showing the Sports Hall to the top left
moving across to the gym before the Squash
Courts with the second gym area below the
squash court. The annex building shows
the current change in toilet and office
areas. Image two. The existing first
floor plan shows the studios that are
used primarily for exercise
classes and indoor cycling
classes. Image Three. The blue areas noted on
the plan indicate the proposed gym extension
achieved by removing some smaller areas of
internal walls and moving into the second
squash court area. These changes will enable
the targeted growth to the gym facilities. A
new downstairs exercise studio will be created
using court space from the Sports Hall that will
allow exercise program growth and enable the
opportunity for an accessible studio for our
current and future users. Alongside female and
male toilets, changing and shower facilities,
a village changing area will create accessible
changing areas for those needing supported
access including family changing areas, private
showers with changing cubicles are also planned
in this area. The reception entrance will be
relocated to the car park side of the building,
providing users with easier access
to the centre. Image four. The main
exercise studio will extend across the newly
created downstairs studio enabling a greater
studio capacity that will provide more space for
users to attend excise classes and activities.
The indoor cycling studio will be extended
slightly to increase the capacity in this area
too. Image five. Here is a visual representation
of the proposed new reception entrance which will
be more conveniently located
for our users to access the
centre. Image six. The existing building
elevations are noted on this slide.
Image seven. Proposed elevations are illustrated.
The west elevation shows the outside of the indoor
cycling studio to the top right of the first
image. Cladding is proposed to reduce the
thermal gains experienced in this area to help
maintain a more suitable exercise environment,
alongside improved air Handling Systems
planned internally will maintain more
appropriate temperatures. The north
elevation shown in the bottom image
offers a further indication of the proposed
new reception entrance of the facility. Our
consultation runs until the 19th of January
2024 and we would welcome your feedback